we will continue taking call 617 830 for
750 is the number who's on next with me
privacy Steve Steve were you calling
from Boston Boston you are where we are
okay you do want to tell us what
neighborhood you're in sure I'm in our
government center actually okay
beautiful i'm sure you're enjoying the
new uh subway stop there known as the
tea of course to people who live in
boston uh but let's not waste time on
that what what's on your mind today uh
well i mean pretty much probably was on
everybody else's mind that this election
is just completely just made me
disgusted in in so many different ways
but you know in in talking about the
vice presidential debate yesterday and
now listen to all these people talk
about how mike pence 1 and he was more
calm and maybe that's true but the bar
that has been set so low for the
Republican Party and Donald Trump and
his part of the election here is just
mad I mean since when can you win a
debate by lie right now me it did not
you never seen anything like that you're
completely right that because the
expectation and the bar is so skewed by
showing up and basically just looking at
the camera in a way that seemed more
confident than Cain and straight up
denying all of the accurate allegations
from Cain mostly accurate allegations
from Cain about what Trump said many
people who just don't even really get
what's going on came away saying WOW
pence looked strong and Cain looked uh
uh not confident in sort of weak it's
just embarrassing and we we talked about
it extensively after the debate it just
doesn't make any sense pence could not
defend a basically any of the things
trumpet said because they are completely
indefensible and it's you know the thing
though is it's not surprising because if
the average voting public actually cared
about the substance of what was said in
the vice presidential debate amazing to
make Trump probably would never be the
nominee in the first place you know what
I mean so I don't think it's even that
surprising the way it went that that how
that it went the way it did but I
completely agree with you
yeah I mean and I think you have to
blame the media offered as well I mean
they this this idea of false equivalency
that okay like for example another thing
that drives me insane is that just
because Donald Trump had a terrible
debate and he went after a Miss Universe
contestant and and whatnot on Twitter
yeah they had to drum up another
controversy that just because Hillary
Clinton said what I think to be a very
accurate statement about Millennials and
you know they are living in their
parents basement there's a lack of
opportunity they had to create a
controversy where there really wasn't
one yeah now you're completely right
under your analysis i think is spot-on
and is this is such a backwards race
it's hard to even believe it's reality
what I'm hoping is that after november
eighth Trump will disappear and we can
all sort of pretend this didn't happen i
know if that happens the republican
party will definitely be pretending
Trump never happened but it may not go
that way so that's why everybody needs
to vote just about a month from now
thanks so much for the call i love
getting calls from boston appreciate it
we do have to move on but uh really
great points glad you made them gamefly
is sort of like netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com /
tdps